the families who have experienced such
grief and such loss since the
extraordinary tragedy on Monday and that
today was all about reuniting them with
their loved ones we know that
reunification won't ease that sense of
loss or grief because I don't think
anything can but we felt an enormous
duty of care as New Zealanders to make
sure that we bought their family members
back our focus has been making sure that
they receive the very best immediate
care that they need in the aftermath of
this tragedy I've visited some of our
health services we've extraordinary
health professionals in New Zealand but
at the same time a desire to make sure
that loved ones are able to be close
with their loved ones who may have been
injured there has been a process
particularly for those from Australia
not least because of the proximity over
the coming period of time we've managed
to medevac all as I understand but one
will over at least if they have not
already well over the coming days be
repatriated and middie vector to
Australia for others at this stage I do
not believe there are other plans in
place yet but till that time they will
be in the very best of care here this is
a volcano that has been visited for the
better part of 30 years however we also
hear and absolutely agree that there are
questions that are being asked that must
be answered and they will be as has
already been said this week WorkSafe is
the agency in New Zealand that will hold
responsibility for that and as you'd
expect where you have significant loss
of life at Colonial inquest as well and
those are the processes that will allow
us a space to answer those questions
because of course they they must be
answered I want to ensure though that no
one predetermines anything in this time
and place that we allow that work to be
done properly and that we give those
experts the time to do
and that we will service peak just the
face that we're in now where families
have only just had their loved ones come
back
you